[Music]
i bet that she knows
[Music]
oh yeah it's no deja vu it's a totally
new experience as olivia rodrigo joins
billy joel on stage at madison square
garden
[Music]
on wednesday the 19 year old singer
surprised fans at billy's concert to
perform two songs her hit deja vu which
he's of course mentioned in
[Music]
oh yeah pretty cool to get to shout out
the piano man irlow
[Music]
talk about manifesting things into
existence and everything's gonna work
out and it always does and that
performance a beautiful transition into
the two singing his 1973 hit uptown girl
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you billy i love you
and olivia's still not over this moment
alongside a video from the crowd she
wrote i sang with billy joel at madison
square garden today are you kidding
olivia also shared this selfie with the
piano man and gushed biggest honor ever
still crying thank you billy i'm just so
happy that i get to do this for a living
and there was just as much excitement on
billy's insta he wrote good for you if
you made it to the garden tonight we see
what you did there billy
olivia joined billy as he hit a
milestone the concert was his 82nd
monthly show at msg he started playing
once a month at the venue back in 2014.
i thought it would really start to drop
off
i thought maybe a year
maybe a little more than a year and it
would be kind of an arc to it and it
would tend to
dissipate yeah and now the tickets are
selling faster than at the beginning
yeah so i may be doing this for the rest
of my natural life
but i'm not complaining it's the best
job i ever had and we have no complaints
either especially if you keep pulling
off surprises like this one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you